so i had planned of course to begin
today talking about the verdict
in the chauvin trial a verdict that was
reached by the jury hours after the
president united states went on tv and
publicly called for a guilty verdict
also shortly after the mayor of the city
demanded a conviction and only a day
after one of the most prominent members
of congress flew from dc to minneapolis
to inflame the already violent mob it
was a verdict reached by a jury in the
same city that had been devastated by
riots last year because of this case and
where even worse riots would have
happened had they
returned anything but the verdict they
did return a verdict reached in a trial
that
could have been moved to a different
city and could have involved the
sequestering of the jury for the whole
trial but that
but it wasn't and didn't even aside from
the facts of the case facts which
very clearly amount to reasonable doubt
on all charges in my opinion
rather than a conviction on all charges
which is what the jury decided
but even aside from those facts the
public pressure the location the refusal
by the judge to take any steps
whatsoever to address any of these
issues
all of that is enough to call this a
fundamentally unfair and unjust trial
and one in which the verdict cannot be
trusted i mean
moving the trial's location and
sequestering the jury these are tools
that a judge has in his toolbox
if this trial didn't call for those
things
then what trial in history ever has
this is why this is a decision which
should be appealed and retried but it
may never get that far because
almost everyone in this country
especially
in positions of leadership including in
the court system is too afraid of the
mob to do the right thing
there should have been a mistrial
declared at various points along the way
but certainly when maxine water showed
up
and did what she did that should have a
mistrial
but courage is in short supply in this
country though we've never needed it
more
there's never been so little of it but
as i said this is the topic that i was
gonna open the show with we'll talk more
about that
later that was until a new case a new
protest
a new blm martyr was appointed right as
the guilty verdict in the chauvin case
was read blm protesters
were descending on columbus ohio in
response to a police shooting
that had happened just hours earlier now
as we've seen over and over again
the narrative takes shape solidifies
metastasizes like a cancerous tumor
rapidly i mean within minutes within
seconds now and this time as almost
always
the narrative was that the victim 16
year old
mikaya bryant was innocent unarmed
helpless not a threat to anyone and had
been gunned down
randomly by police police showed up and
just shot her dead that's basically what
we were told
activists and media journalists but i
repeat myself took the words of the
supposed witnesses and the supposed
victims family
and ran with it as gospel truth as they
always do
before any other facts here's here's the
point we're at now before any other
facts about this case had circulated
already this video clip of mikaya
bryant's mother
now she was out in front of cameras
uh right away right away within minutes
within within hours at least
and before we knew anything else this
was the clip making the rounds and this
is what established
the narrative uh here's what mikhail
bryant's mother said let's listen
makaya was named after a male prophet in
the bible
she was a very loving peaceful
little girl she was 16 years old she was
an honorable student
and um makaya had a motherly
nature about her she promoted peace
and that's something that i wanted to
always be remembered
loving motherly and honorable student
she promoted peace
that's what her mother says her mother
we should note
did not have legal custody of her
daughter makaya was in foster care
even more important to note the loving
and peaceful micaiah was actually shot
by cops while in the process of trying
to murder somebody with a knife
the same day as the shooting um only
hours after
after the shooting happened actually
columbus police held a press conference
and uh you know usually like takes a
couple of days but now we're at a point
now where just
they they put the body cam footage out
right away
even that is it's not quick enough if
you can't get it out within seconds it's
not gonna be fast enough
to get out in front of the narrative so
this is a few hours later still not fast
enough
but they showed the body cam footage and
explained the context of the shooting
and let's watch that now 71 legion
lane the information was that a caller
said females were there trying to stab
them and put their hands on them
dispatchers tried to obtain information
about weapons but were unable to gather
that information
officers were dispatched at 4 36
and arrived at 4 44. we will play the
first video
in real time
[Music]
hey get down
[Music]
there's there's the body confusion so
the cops were called to the scene
because someone was trying to stab
somebody else
that's all they know police officer
arrives
sees a woman wielding a large knife
appears to be a butcher's knife or steak
knife that you get from your kitchen
i mean this is the point is this is no
pocket knife this is a large knife
the suspect attacks one other woman and
pushes her to the ground
and then she goes after someone else the
girl in pink in the body cam footage
mikaya pins the girl in pink against the
car
raises the knife and is in the process
of trying to stab her
when the officer given no other choice
from his perspective opens fire
makaya was not unarmed she had a knife
she was not peaceful at least in that
video she was trying to stab someone
these details matter at least they
matter to those of us who are honest and
rational though our club is
small and losing members by the day
the full facts of the case as they've
now been revealed facts which
absolutely without any shadow of a doubt
vindicate the police officer and reveal
him to be not just justified but heroic
acting to save someone's life but of
course that doesn't matter none of it
matters
still the cop is accused not just of
murder but of racist
murder this is part of the fact that he
was firing
not even to defend himself but to defend
the life of another black girl
he shot a black girl to stop her from
killing another black girl
and that makes him a homicidal racist
there's no reasoning with this thinking
because there's no thinking involved the
left
needs this is what the left needs to
know they need to know only two things
two data points
did the police kill someone and was that
person black if so it was racism every
time without exception
now let's let's really consider the
position
this officer was in he's called
to the scene he finds a black girl
trying to
gut another black girl with a butcher's
knife
if he shoots he's racist if he doesn't
shoot
and the other black girl gets stabbed
and killed right in front of him
he'll be accused of not acting to save
the life of that
black child so if he saves the black
girl's life
then he's guilty of not valuing the
assailant's life
he doesn't save her life he's guilty of
not valuing the victim's life
and because they're both black then no
matter what he does he's
not valuing the life of one or the other
of the black people involved
no matter what he does he loses no
matter what he does
he's already condemned simply for
arriving to the scene
the moment he is there wearing that
badge he's done
there's nothing he can do no option he
can avail himself of
that would not lead to accusations of
racism
of course you're always going to get the
monday morning quarterback
why didn't you use a taser
when someone is in the process
they've got the knife like this and
they're in the process of trying to stab
a taser is by no means guaranteed to
stop that from happening
you could shoot them with the taser and
they'll still get that stab in
they could get multiple blows in
certainly at least one
that could a knife that size a blade
that size
could even just one stab placed in the
right place
could very easily kill somebody
so if he had done that if he had just
pulled the taser out tried to use a
taser
and um and it wasn't enough and
and the the the girl was stabbed to
death
then what would the activist be saying
you know what they'd be saying they'd be
saying oh
yeah well now you use a taser because uh
because it's not important enough to you
to use lethal force to save this black
child's life
that's what they would say and we all
know it
so there's no option except for one
perhaps here's the other option if
you're a cop
um don't take the call you know there
was some static over the radio you
didn't hear it
oops these things happen go grab a
coffee instead
stay out of it let whatever's gonna
happen happen
the other members of the community there
you see him in the video
there appear to be some adults there as
well um
they don't seem too concerned about
these kids lives anyway they're just
standing around watching
like a night fight between teenagers is
a spectator sport
so let the violence happen stay far away
from it
if parents don't want to raise their
children
if communities don't want to care for
themselves
then let them reap what they sow what we
know for sure
is that if the cops had done that if
mackay had simply been had simply been
allowed to
stab the other girl to death and no cop
was in the vicinity
that we'd never hear a word about it blm
wouldn't care
you wouldn't have people on the media in
the media weeping and wailing oh no
another black life take it i'm so
distraught
they wouldn't be saying that any of that
at all they wouldn't say a damn word
about it
there'd be no protest no outrage no
morning
because there'd be no political or
ideological benefit to any of that
the left needs the cops involved for
that
so if the real way for the police to
avoid the lose-lose situation is to
avoid the situation completely
and yet you know they still respond to
the call
they still show up to the scene it turns
out lots of cops really do care about
protecting and serving
even protecting and serving communities
that wouldn't spit on them if they were
on fire in fact they probably lit the
fire
now cops aren't superhuman they aren't
superheroes they aren't perfect they
aren't saints nobody is but
i can't imagine why any of them would
still be on the job
at this point if they didn't at least
care about helping and protecting people
why else would you be there now what
other motivation
could you possibly have sadly for them
they're doing that job in a culture that
doesn't care about
justice and truth doesn't care about the
rule of law doesn't care about human
life
except when it can be used as i talk
about all the time
human life in this culture all human
life
black or white um is a commodity
it's something to be used
if you can't use it then uh you just
throw it away like it like it doesn't
exist
we do that in the womb
just wait we call it in the womb if a
life is taken in the womb
we call it medical waste throw it in a
medical waste dumpster out back
of the abortion clinic
so life only has value when it can be
used
and when it comes to black lives
in the city from the media's perspective
and our cultural perspective
they have value after the life has
already been taken
if it was taken in a circumstance as
politically advantageous
to the cultural powers that be
the culture we live in a culture
governed not by mob rule
okay let's get that straight this this
is not mob rule
this is a culture governed by the rule
of leftist elites
who use the mob to affect their ends
and and that has made many things very
difficult to merely live
as a normal and decent person
maintaining your decency insanity amid
deterrent
is at times a herculean task for
everybody
but to enforce the law in this culture
in this environment
with your life and the lives of others
on the line
[Music]
that is now almost impossible
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content